Android Studio is an incredibly
powerful piece of software.
It has an editor with
sophisticated code completion,
and static analysis features.
It also has a suite of tools for
integrating with Android devices and
emulators.
The one thing it doesn't have, however,
is an integrated build system.
Android Studio delegates the entire
build process to Gradle.
That's everything that happens
to turn your sources and
resources into an APK that you
can install on your device.
Gradle itself doesn't inherently
know anything about Android.
That capability's provided by Google in
the form of an Android Gradle plugin.
Android Studio is actually happy to
import and work with any Gradle project.
We can use it to do all
sorts of interesting things,
like build Java libraries or deploy
a backend service to Google App Engine.
Even though Android Studio
isn't building your project,
it still needs a deep
model of your project, so
it can provide features like code
completion, and auto importing.
It maintains its own internal
model of your project, and
when a project is loaded or
a Gradle build script changes,
Android Studio needs to synchronize its
internal model with Gradle's model.
When you get a "failed to sync" message,
it usually means you've just got
an error in one of your build scripts.